good morning john here in the u.s it is
10 days away from our general election
it's a big election it's an important
election and i would like to
encourage everyone to vote right now if
you're on the fence about whether
to vote or if you know someone who is
i'm just going to give you 10 reasons
why it's great to vote right now and if
you can't vote right now which in some
states you have to wait until election
day then right now you need to make a
plan for when and how you are going to
vote on november 3rd number one
it tends to be quick and easy now long
lines are a problem in some places but
94 of americans will be in and out in
less than 30 minutes now that number
should be 100 and it's a big deal that
it is reporting on long wait times is
really important because we have to fix
those problems but
hearing about long wait times
discourages people from voting even in
places where wait times are shorter
reason number two to vote
on every day of the year you are less
powerful than bill gates but not in this
one way
you get the same number of votes as the
richest people in america and you get
more votes
than any of the organizations or
corporations that we are always worrying
about let me tell you jeff bezos is
voting
like you know that number three your
vote influences the lives of people
beyond just you your neighbors but also
people all over the world the united
states is a very powerful country and we
have a responsibility as citizens to
engage with that power
number four we get really caught up in
thinking about
one election every four years but there
are tons of local elections that matter
so much from congress people all the way
to
mayors and city councilors and school
board members now you don't have to vote
on
everything like if you don't feel like
you have a dog in the hunt if you don't
feel educated on something you can
absolutely leave stuff playing but i
live in montana where we have a
democratic governor and we have a
democratic senator and that would not
happen if all the people who are like
well trump's gonna win anyway didn't go
to the polls reason number five
margins matter politicians know that
they can get away with more extreme
beliefs and actions
if they won by like 20 percentage points
versus if they won by five reason number
six
the people who are calling you on the
phone to tell you to vote right now
actually get a list every day of the
people who have already voted and they
will stop calling you
so that's nice reason number seven the
fact that any individual election that
you vote in is unlikely to be decided by
one vote
should only discourage people who want
to be the autocrat like do you think
that you should be the deciding vote in
everything no
we are doing this together that's what
democracy is reason number eight listen
to this lady from boston
i want to go to the fenway because we've
all been cooked up inside for a little
bit
and i got my donkeys i'm ready to vote
for joe biden but i wish i was voting
for bernie sanders
but it's a team sport it's a team sport
get your donkeys in play
reason number nine this election is a
big deal it will be and it should be
interpreted
as a judgment on the way that we've done
things for the last four years and that
internationally that's how we
communicate with each other that's how
we treat each other we don't just vote
for people we vote for a story and what
that story
is and what that means for this country
what it means for the future
of the whole world like that it matters
a lot the story of a narrow win
is very different from the story of a
landslide finally reason number 10 the
reason that you should vote right now if
you can or make a plan right now if you
can
is if you don't you might not vote this
is just general procrastination advice
and stuff that we know
if you want to do something you just
have to do it you
don't like wait for the perfect time or
if you are recognize that
this is the perfect time if the ballot
is sitting on your kitchen table or
you're not sure how you're going to get
yourself to the polls on november 3rd
make that plan now send that ballot now
and if you're not sure how any of this
works in your state
you can go to youtube.com how to vote in
every state look up your state the video
is less than two minutes long
watch it right now john let's do this
i'll see you on tuesday